mark zuckerberg has had a couple of
rough months but he's planning a
comeback even though his company's stock
is down nearly 50 percent he's not
worried about it see zuck is in a very
unique position even though metta has
lost hundreds of billions of dollars in
value since the peak of the metaverse
hype wave they aren't taking their foot
off the gas
zuck is extremely motivated to build the
metaverse and he knows it's not gonna
happen overnight he has a chip on his
shoulder right now and if he can pull it
off he'll make every youtube video about
him struggling look ridiculous in
hindsight so what's his plan well zuck
has a few tricks left up his sleeve but
let's start with artificial intelligence
if you ask a random person what
technologies will be most important in
the metaverse they will almost always
say virtual reality and that's not wrong
vr is going to be important but a big
part of the problem with vr right now is
that there just isn't much to do once
you put on a headset the experiences
aren't very immersive and the amount of
content is pretty meager but ai can help
here we're still years away from massive
virtual worlds being built automatically
by ai but there are dozens of small
places where ai can speed up development
and improve user experience one of the
big ideas underpinning this whole
metaverse thing is the ability to move
digital assets from one virtual world to
another but whenever i mention the idea
of bringing a fortnight skin into a
different game like minecraft i
immediately get tons of comments saying
that it's impossible because different
games use different file formats and
rendering technologies and that's true
but ai could make it a lot easier to
translate assets from one system to
another that technology doesn't exist
yet but ai is already handling other
translation tasks incredibly well so
well in fact that when zuck hosted the
most recent meta ai event translation
was one of the main topics zuck is
planning on spending 180 billion dollars
on the metaverse and a decent chunk of
that is going to be used to develop
advanced ai to make the metaverse feel
more immersive we've all seen how
important hand presence is in cinematic
depictions of vr the current oculus
touch controllers are pretty good but
you're never really fooled into thinking
that your hands are actually there in
the virtual world still feels like
you're holding a controller but zuck and
his team are working on ways to change
that deep learning models are already
getting pretty good at hand tracking but
the meta ai team isn't stopping there
they recently developed a system called
reskin which uses a deformable membrane
with embedded magnetic particles to
detect movement as the hand moves the
magnetic signal changes then ai is used
to interpret that signal and detect
where the glove is making contact none
of that matters though unless you
actually have a virtual world that you
want to interact with and that's where
zuck's second big announcement comes in
builderbot is a new ai that takes in
simple descriptions of environments in
plain english and then produces 3d
worlds to match that input building
virtual worlds is getting easier every
year but even a state-of-the-art
platform like unreal engine 5 still
requires a decent amount of technical
expertise to get up and running by
developing this builderbot ai the hope
is that everyone regardless of their
background will be able to create
exactly what they want in the metaverse
bringing other useful tools into the
metaverse will be important as well so
the meta ai team is working on next
generation virtual assistants current
chatbots are pretty bad but it's because
most of them use outdated technology
machine learning is used to recognize
speech but pretty much everything else
has to be coded by hand meta's ai team
is working on changing this by building
a system called karaoke that processes
the entire bot interaction through
machine learning this ai will still use
traditional apis to do specific tasks
like find the weather forecast but
essentially your entire interaction will
be fed through a deep learning algorithm
by layering in more and more artificial
intelligence these bots should start to
become extremely reliable and then
become available in virtual worlds
through avatars training these new
models is no easy feat though meta has
an incredible amount of data but
actually using it all to train a new
system requires a massive supercomputer
zuck has been investing in ai hardware
for nearly a decade now and is on the
cusp of rolling out the fastest ai
supercomputer in the world it's called
the ai research supercluster and it
already has over 6000 top-tier nvidia
gpus installed with another 10 000
coming online soon this will allow meta
to train models with more than a
trillion parameters on data sets as
large as an exabyte which is the
equivalent of 36 000 years of high
quality video that might sound
unnecessary but deep learning thrives on
massive data sets there's a reason why
deep learning has become the go-to
method for building state-of-the-art ai
systems it scales incredibly well as you
add more and more data the results just
get more and more reliable and you don't
really need to change that much of the
code to get these performance
improvements this computing power allows
meta's ai team to tackle increasingly
complex problems we've had decent
translation for years now but there have
always been drawbacks to the automated
approach google translate launched in
2006 and used statistical machine
translation to convert english to other
languages it wasn't great at grammar
though billions of people use facebook
instagram and whatsapp but because of
language barriers they can't all easily
communicate with each other zuck wants
to change that by improving translation
using ai and his team is working on a
unique approach instead of taking what
someone said transcribing into text
translating that text and then
generating the resulting speech his ai
team is working on going directly from
speech in one language to speech in
another they're effectively cutting out
the middleman which has been a source of
pesky heirs for years it's a subtle
change but if it works audio translation
should get a lot better now zuck is in a
strong position to do this precisely
because meta has so much training data
and the super computer to process it all
but data and hardware are just one piece
of the puzzle here all those resources
are meaningless if you don't have
talented people working on these
problems fortunately for zuck he has one
of the best researchers in the world
leading his ai team his name is yan
lacoon and he's one of the fathers of
deep learning he pioneered this approach
alongside jeffrey hinton and joshua
benjio in the early 2000s and is now
recognized as one of the best computer
scientists in history it wasn't always
so clear that lacoon's approach would
work though in traditional computing a
program directs the computer with
explicit step-by-step instructions and
pretty much everyone thought this would
always be the right way to do things
this approach was stalling out though it
was great when tasks were clearly
defined
but when you gave a computer an entirely
novel situation it would struggle
artificial intelligence research was
going nowhere fast and we entered an ai
winter lacoone and his associates kept
the candle burning and eventually turned
things around advances in computer
hardware and access to larger data sets
finally came together to allow deep
learning to take off and the ai
community hasn't looked back everything
from self-driving cars to tagging photos
of cats taken with mobile phones uses
deep learning these days but recently a
new challenger has emerged his name is
gary marcus and he believes that all
this deep learning stuff is overhyped
could zuckerberg and lacoon be heading
toward a dead end well that's what gary
marcus alleges in a recent article he
published but why does he think that
well for one in 2014 he founded an ai
company that was built around a
different model of ai development called
symbol manipulation the basic idea is
that instead of giving an ai model a big
pile of data and just letting it figure
out the important connections engineers
code specific symbols to represent
important details about the real world
sounds good in theory but things get a
lot more complicated in practice see
while it might be straightforward to
hard code symbols for everyday objects
like tables and chairs you'll quickly
run into problems as you try to scale up
with deep learning going from 90
accuracy to 95 accuracy might require 10
times more data but it probably won't
require 10 times the amount of
engineering effort but getting that same
performance improvement using symbol
manipulation might actually require 10
times the amount of human effort and
that's just unrealistic now is it
possible that the deep learning
community is missing something though we
certainly don't have human level ai yet
and we don't even really have fully
self-driving cars even yan lacoon admits
that deep learning isn't perfect how is
it that most teenagers can learn to
drive a car in about 20 hours of
practice whereas even with millions of
hours of
simulated practice a self-driving car
can't actually learn to drive itself
properly and so obviously we're missing
something you know the immediate
response you get from many people is
well you know humans use their
background knowledge to learn faster and
they're right now how was that
background knowledge required and that's
the big question ai researchers are
racing to develop new machine learning
models that can include this background
knowledge once a system has an accurate
world model teaching an ai to handle a
new task should be trivial and simple
manipulation feels like it could be the
perfect fit for this there's only one
problem though across the board deep
learning is absolutely crushing symbolic
models gary marcus claims that deep
learning is hitting a wall but as recent
performance shows if deep learning is
hitting a wall that wall is getting
completely demolished even still both
yan lacoon and gary marcus might be
biased in their outlooks both have built
entire careers around their respective
methodologies so we need to dig deeper
in order to get a straight answer i
called up my friend charles he spent
years working on machine learning at
google but more importantly he's
independent now he's building a new
startup that uses machine learning and
he doesn't have a boss dictating a
particular direction to him but here's
the thing when it came to start building
he's stuck with a deep learning approach
sure that's what he's familiar with but
the bigger reason he chose deep learning
is because of how these models scale his
startup is small so he doesn't have a
lot of data yet but as he grows he'll be
able to feed his model more and more
data and instantly get better results if
he was building a symbolic model every
incremental improvement would require
painstaking engineering effort you can
see how he's thinking about scale on his
youtube channel which i'll link to below
charles story is interesting not just
for the technical reasons though it also
highlights an important trend that
brings us back to zuckerberg talented
engineers are hard to retain hiring the
best engineers is clearly a cornerstone
of zuck's metaverse strategy we've seen
how big his vision is for this thing and
it's clearly going to take years to come
to fruition better vr headsets new
immersive applications and complex ai
systems to power it all are going to
require top-notch talent to develop and
the competition is heating up one of the
classic tools that big tech companies
use to convince talented individuals to
come on board has always been stock
options joining a company like facebook
in the early days could quickly make you
a millionaire if you played your cards
right but with the stock price falling
these options aren't as attractive as
they used to be now meta has plenty of
cash so it shouldn't be a problem right
well it's a little more complex than
that see when high growth tech companies
report their financials to wall street
they typically break out stock-based
compensation as a separate line item and
for better or worse investors have
historically focused on operating income
figures that exclude the cost of stock
options this can have a significant
impact on the true financial performance
of a company take shopify for example
when you exclude stock options they had
a margin of nine percent not bad but
including those stock options drops
their margin to just one percent if
investors expect zuckerberg to start
paying employees more in cash it could
hurt how they view meta's prospects
ultimately though compensation is just
one piece of the puzzle talented machine
learning engineers want to go work on
hard problems with smart people and
that's a big part of why meta is hosting
these ai focused events but whether you
go work for a big tech company or you
build your own startup you'll eventually
need to decide what to do with your
money and that's where channel sponsor
masterworks.io comes in see it might be
decades until we understand how the
price of art moves in the metaverse but
we have plenty of data about art in the
real world now contemporary art prices
outpaced the s p 500 total return by 164
percent from 1995 to 2021. the problem
is that typically you had to be
incredibly wealthy to build a real
portfolio of fine art masterwork solves
this problem and allows you to invest in
world famous artworks from banksy monet
and other iconic artists for just a
fraction of what these pieces typically
cost all you need to do is create an
account on their website browse their
artwork and then start diversifying your
portfolio with one of the most stable
assets around masterworks is unlocking a
new market if you like a particular
artist you don't have to spend millions
of dollars to buy a full piece you can
trade shares with other members just
like you would sell a stock on a trading
app i'll leave a link in the description
to skip the wait list and if you'd like
to know more about the history of vr
just go watch this video about the
founder of oculus palmer lucky thanks
for watching